hi everyone
welcome to this section of our
programming let's learn about data
manipulation in
r and here we will learn about
d player package and when we talk about
this d player package
it is much faster and much easier to
read
than base r so d player package
is used to transform and summarize
tabular data with rows and columns
you might be working on a data frame or
you might be getting in a
inbuilt r data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get
this package deployer by just
calling in library function and this can
be used for grouping by data
summarizing the data adding new
variables
selecting different set of columns
filtering our data sets
sorting it selecting it arranging it
or even mutating that is basically
creating new columns
using functions on existing variables
so let's see how we work with d player
now here
i can basically get the package here
so i can just say install dot packages d
plier now we already see the the package
here
which is showing up so i will just
select this one i can do a control
enter and that will basically set up the
package
package deep player successfully
unpacked so that is done
now you can start using this package by
just doing a library d plier
and this was built it shows me my
version of r
so let's also use a inbuilt data set
that is new york flights 13 so we can do
install dot packages
and that will search and get that
relevant data set
i can again call it by using library
function
now once that is done we can look at
some sample data here
by just doing view flights and that
shows me the data in a
neat and a tabular format which shows me
year
month day departure time schedule
departure time and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data
which can help us in understanding the
data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here
it shows me how many variables we have
so this is fine
now we can start using the player and
in that we can use say filter function
if we would want to look in for
specific value now here we have the
column as
month so i will do a filter
now i'm creating a variable f1 i'm using
the filter function
on flights which we already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically
look at the month where the month value
is 0
7 so let's look at that
and this one you can do a view on
f1 which shows me the data wherein you
have filtered out
all the data based on month being 7. so
this is a simple usage of filter we can
take some other example we
may want to include multiple columns so
we can say
f2 filter flights and here we will say
month is equal to seven day is three
and then look at the value of f2 if you
are interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month is seven
and days three
you could also look into a more readable
format by using
view on f2 and that gives me my selected
result so we are just extracting in
some specific value we can keep
extending this
so here we can say flights is what we
would want to work on
i'm using the filter function so i can
straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view
i can also do a view in this way i can
just pass in my
filter within the view and within this i
am saying
filter i would want to look at the
flights month being 0
9 day being 2 and origin being
lga and then that shows me the value
here
and obviously you can scroll and look at
all the columns and if you see the
origin column it shows the selected
value so now
we have filtered out our data based on
values
in three different columns now what we
can also do is
we can use and or we can use
or operators so i could have done
this in a a little different way so i
could have said
head which shows me initial result
i will do a flight so within my head
function i am passing in this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights
and in this flights data set you would
want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we given a value
and i'll say and and i'll again say
flights
wherein i will select the day being 2
and and and remember when you talk about
and
it is going to check if all the values
are met
true so then you say flights origin
lga and you look at the value so
in this way i can filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now
we could have done it in this way we
could have created a view or we could
have assigned this to a
variable and then done a view on that
where we could have selected
month being day and origin or
you can be more specific
in specifying all the columns it makes
the code more readable
so let's look at the values and here you
are looking at head
which shows me based on month day
and then you can look for further
columns for other variables that is
origin being lga now what we can also do
is we can do some slicing here
to select rows by particular position
so i can say slice and i would want to
look at
rows one two five and i can do this
so you can always assign or look at the
view
of this i can just do here
so when i did a slide one is to five
it shows me my entries
for one to five now similarly
we can do is slice 5 to 10
and now you are looking at 5 to 10
values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to
apply some variable on a particular data
set
and then you would want to add it to
your existing data frame or you would
want
to add a new column so this is where you
use
mutate which is mainly used to add new
variables
so let's see how you work on mutate so
it's pretty simple so you create a
variable over delay
now i would want to do a mutate so that
it adds a new column
so i'm selecting my data which is flight
i will call the new column as
overall delay and then basically
i can look at overall delay being
arrival delay minus departure delay so
let's create this
and let's look at view of this which
shows me
or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay
which was not in my original data set so
you can any time
do a head on this one to compare
the value so this one shows me arrival
delay and then there are many other
variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view
and you could have just look at flights
if you would want to compare
so you can look at the flights and this
one would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here and if you
do a view on overall delay
then that basically shows me 20 columns
so we know that the new column has been
added
to this overall delay so if you would
want to work with 20 columns you will
use overall delay
if you would want to work with your
original data set you will use flights
now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show
only the new column so we can do an
overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay
the computation remains same but at this
time
if i look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute
result based on two variables or two
columns and just look at the new value
and then we can decide if we would want
to add it to our existing structure
now you can also use summarize and
summarize basically helps us
in getting a summary based on
certain criteria so we can always do a
summarize and what we can do
is we can look at our data and we can
say
on what basis we would want to summarize
this particular data
so we can do a summarize function now
summarize on flights
i will say average a time and i would
want to calculate
an average so for that i am using
inbuilt function called mean
i will do that on airtime column
so let's look at flights once again
and here we can see there is arrival
time not a time sorry arrival time
and we would want to do some average on
this particular data we would want to
summarize this
so what i'll do is i will use the
summarize function
i will say average airtime and this one
i will look at mean of a time so let's
see if
there is a airtime column i might be
let's look at this one and i will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at
summarizing based on airtime not the
arrival time
so air time is how much time it takes in
air for this particular fight
and we will want to use the trans
summarize
function not the transmute so summarize
flights
average a time and this one we will
calculate the mean
of average a time and i will also do a
any removal which is i'm saying true so
let's do this
and that basically shows me the average
a time is 151
i can also do a total airtime where i am
doing a summation
of values or i can get the standard
deviation
or i can basically get multiple values
such as mean
i can say total airtime where i am doing
a summation
and then i can look at other values
which is
if you would want to put in standard
deviation here you could do that
so let's look at the result of this
summarize and this basically
allows me to get some useful information
which is
summarized based on a particular
function such as mean
sum standard deviation or
all three of them now let's look at
grouping by so sometimes we may be
interested in
summarizing the data by groups and
that's where we use the group by
function
so we can always use
the group by clause now
here we are taking a different data set
so we will say for example let's look at
head of mt cars
and that is basically my data set on
empty cars
now that shows me the model of the car
it shows me my lathe
cylinder power this and your horsepower
and various other characteristics or
variables in this particular data set
so here we can say let's do a grouping
by
gear so there is a column called gear so
i will call it by gear
i will look at my data set and then what
i am using
here which you see with these percentage
and greater symbol
is called piping so that basically
feeds your previous data frame into next
one so this is sometimes useful
and you can get this by just saying
control shift and
m and you can then use this so we are
going to
have piping so i am saying empty cars
now this is my original data set
where i did a head or i could have done
a view
on this one if you would want to see it
in a more
readable format and that basically shows
me the data
so we are using a different data set so
i want to group it by
the gear column so i'm going to call it
by gear
and this one takes my data that is empty
cars
i'm using the piping and then i'm saying
group the data based on gear column
that's done now let's look at the value
of by gear
or you can always do a view
so remember whenever you are doing a
group by it is giving you
a internal object where your data is
grouped based
on a particular column so we can look at
the values here
you can do a view that shows you your
data grouped based on
a particular column now i can again use
the summarize function
where i would want to now work on the
new one
where it was grouped based on gear so
i'm doing a summarize
and here i am going to say gear 1
which will be having the value of
summation
on the gear column and then i am saying
gear
2 which is mean well you could give some
meaningful names to this
and let's look at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is
sum and mean values based on
the gear similarly we can use look at
different example
so we can say by gear and i am again
using piping
but earlier we had taken gear
we had grouped the data and we called it
by gear so we took our original data set
empty cars but now
within this particular data which was
grouped by gear
i will take this data set i will use the
piping
and i will summarize it where i am
saying
within this particular data set i would
want to get the sum
or i would want to get the mean and then
you can look at the values
so what you're doing is you are
either looking at your original data set
or you are looking at the data which was
already grouped and then you can look at
the values
now here what we can do is we can group
by cylinder
say might be you are interested in
looking at data which is summarized
based on the cylinder column
you can do that and then for this
by cylinder i'm doing a piping where i'm
using the summarize function and
summarizing
will then be done based on the mean
values of the gear column
or the horsepower so let's do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point
you may want to look at the data set
again so just go ahead and you can look
at
what does the value contain and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head
and it gives you the value so you can
always do some summarizing or grouping
in these ways now here we
are going to use sample underscore n
function
and sample underscore fraction
for creating samples so for this
let's take the flights data set again
and we would want to get 15 random
values
now that is done and it shows me 15 rows
with some random values from the data
what you can also do is you can do a
portion of data by using sample
underscore fraction and here i'll say
flights i'll say 0.4 which will return
40 percent of the total data
so this can be useful when you are
building your machine learning
where you would want to split your data
into training and test might be you are
interested in some portion of the data
so you can do this which is very useful
function
and then you can look at the value of
that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function
so like we were doing a grouping by or
we were
trying to pull out a particular column
so in the same way
we can use a range which is a convenient
way of sorting
than your base r sorting so for a range
function
let's do a view based on a range
so we will work on the flights data set
which we have
and here what we would want to do is we
would want to arrange the flights data
set
which is based on year and departure
time
and we are doing a view out of it so
that basically
gives me the data which is arranged
based on your year and departure time
now i can do a head to give me some
highlighting of that data now
the piping operator what we are using
can be used in these ways also
so here i will say df i will
just assign the data set empty cars to
it
let's look at the df which has basically
your different models
you can obviously look at the head or
view of it to look at useful information
we can also go for nesting options which
can be useful
so we are creating a variable called
result here
now that has the arrange function so
what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange
to sort the data so i would want to sort
the data
but what data would i sort so i will use
sample n
which will give me some portion of the
data or some sample data now what is
that sample data so here we are using
nesting
that is earlier when we did a sample
we just said data and how many random
samples we want
but instead of giving that what we are
going to do is we are going to use
filter here
now this filter will work on df
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20
i will say size is 5 and i would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so i'm using the des
on this particular mileage column by
default it is always ascending
so let's get the result out of this
which will
basically show me the mileage details in
a descending order
so this is my data frame and now
we can look at the result what we have
created
so just do a view or do a head
and look at the view so here you see
mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values
in a random sample so that's why when
you did a view
it shows your five values and it shows
in a descending order based on mileage
so we have
not only used an inbuilt function we
have not only arranged the data that is
we have sorted the data
but we have sorted the data based on a
descending order
on a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20
and we have also said we just need five
random samples
now let's look at some other examples so
you can always do a multi-assignment
so i can say filter wherein i'm going to
use
df which was assigned empty cars i'm
going to say
mileage should be greater than 20 then
i say b which is going to get a sample
out of a and i just want 5
random values so let's look at that so
we have b
which is going to get a
set of 5 values from a now i will create
a result variable
which will arrange b which is sample
data
in a descending order now let's look at
the result of this
and that basically shows me what we were
seeing earlier
so you can do a multi assignment where
you can create a variable
get a sample out of it and then
basically whatever is that result you
can
arrange that or sort that in a
descending or
by default ascending order so same thing
we can do it using pipe operator so
piping
so here i will say result i'm passing in
my
df that's the data set i'm using piping
and which basically tells what you need
to do on this particular data set so i'm
going to filter out
the data based on mileage 50 sorry
mileage 20
then i'm going to push that or forward
it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it
and then basically you can look at the
result so these are some simple examples
where you can use your d plier
with multiple assignments or using your
nesting to filter out the data
you can also do a arrange which is to
sort the data you can get some random
samples out of it
you can summarize the data you can also
summarize the data based on one or two
or multiple columns
and you can use some inbuilt functions
to summarize the data based on some
functions which are applied on the
variables or on the columns
you can transmute it where you would be
interested in only looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it and you can
give the conditions where you can say
and on or
to filter out the data so what we can
also do
is on this particular data set which we
have say for example df
where i have my data let's look at this
one
and if i just do a df at this point it
shows me
my data set and if you would be
interested
only in particular column then your d
player also allows you to either we can
do a filter
or we can simply do a select
now for selecting we can choose
uh our data so for example i'll say df
underscore i'm interested in mileage i'm
interested in horsepower
might be i am interested in your
cylinders
in this and for this one what i can do
is
when i would want to do a select i can
basically say
selected df let's call it some name
i can say control shift
m which is for piping and then basically
what you can do is you can do a select
and you can choose your columns so i was
interested in mileage
i was interested in horsepower
i was interested in cylinder and here
what i'm doing is i'm using a select
where i can look at the new data frame
so let's do this and
i'm sorry here we will have to give it
df
this is where you are passing in your
data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one
by just doing a df or
head on df
underscore mileage horsepower cylinder
and
look at the selected result so you can
be looking at selective columns
i could have done this filter but filter
will always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than 4
or something else but when you do a
select you are selecting specific
columns
so view always gives you all the columns
head
gives you highlight but then select can
be useful when we are interested in
looking at
only specific data so this is how you
can use the plier
for manipulation for your data
transformation
for basically filtering out the data by
selecting particular
data and then working on it so similarly
there is one more package called tidr
and we'll see how we can use data
manipulation
done using your tidr package let's
learn about that idr package it makes it
easy to
tidy your data and this basically helps
you
creating a more cleaner data so
which is easy to visualize and model
now this comes with mainly four
functions
so you have gather which makes your data
wide or it makes white data longer so
that is basically used to stack
up multiple columns you have spread
function
which makes long data wider that is
stacking the data together or stack
if you would want to unstack the data to
data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes
and then your spread can spread the data
across multiple columns
you have separate which is function
which splits
single column into multiple columns and
to complement that you have one more
function which is unite and that
combines multiple columns into
single columns so these are four main
functions which are used
in your idr package so let's look how we
work with this
so let me bring up my r studio here now
for this
first is let me just clean up my screen
here doing a control
l so i will install the package it is
already installed but we can just do a
control
enter and then i can say do you want to
restart
r prior to reinstall store install i'll
say okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package tid tidy r the rest
idrs
has been successfully unpacked let's use
that package
using our library function
and that was built under our version 3.6
now i can basically start using these
functions so for example here we are
creating a data frame so let's say
n is 10 and then we basically would say
we will call it white now that's the
variable name
i'm using the data.frame function i'm
saying
id which will be 1 to n so that will
take the values from 1 to 10
and then these are the values which have
ten entries so this is a vector phase
one phase two phase three let's create a
data frame out of it
now that's done we can have a look at
our data frame
by just doing a view wide and that shows
me the id column
and it has face dot one face dot two and
face dot
three now we can use our function so for
example we can work with
gather that is reshaping the data from
wide
format to long format and basically you
can say stacking
up multiple columns so let's see how we
do that
here i'll call it long i'm working on
white i'm using the piping
functionality and then i'm using gather
so this one
i will say what will be the data which i
will use
so we are using wide as a data frame
then i am saying response time so that
will be
basically one more column and then you
have your columns which you would want
to
basically stack so i'm saying from phase
one to phase three
so let's do this and once this is done
let's have a look
at our variable long so this one shows
me that i have an id column
i have the response time column and i
have the
face column which we mentioned and that
basically has
all the values stacked in so you have
face dot one face dot two
and face dot three so if all the columns
are being stacked
here so all my data so now i have
totally 30 entries in this one
so this is basically using your gather
function now sometimes we may want to
use a separate function now separate
function is basically splitting
a single column into multiple columns
so which we would want to use when
multiple variables are captured
in a single variable column okay so
let's look at an example of this one
so let's say long separate that's what
we will call we will work on this long
which has
all the data stacked in as the columns
we
selected then i'm saying separate i want
the face column
and then i would say when i separate the
columns what are my column names now i
could also give a separator
by giving a comma and then mentioning
the separator if that is required
so let's do this now once this is done
let's have
a look at our long separate so what we
see here
is the column which we used
so we were doing a face column and that
was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
target
and number so that's what we see here so
you have
face being split into target and number
and then you have the
response time so this is how you use the
separate function
now there is also something called as
unite function which is basically a
complementing of separate function
so it takes multiple columns and
combines the elements to a single column
so for example here we will
call it long unite and we will take long
separate which was separating the data
we want to unite so we will take phase
target
number and we want to have a separator
between them
so let's basically do this and now let's
look at the result
of this unite so you see
you have the face and target merge
together so you have face dot one
the separator is dot as we have
mentioned and we have united multiple
columns
so this is one more function
of your tie dr which helps you basically
tidy up your data or put it in a
particular way
now then you have your spread function
and this is basically for unstacking so
that is
if you have if you would want to convert
a stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is
of same attributes spread can be used so
that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns so
it will take two columns say key and
value and spread it into multiple
columns
so it makes long data wider so we can
look at this one
we will say long unite i'm using the
piping
i will use the spread function i'll work
on the face column
and response time and let's do this and
then let's do a view on this so
it tells me our data is back in the
shape as it was in the beginning
so these are four functions which
are very helpful when we work with tidr
package
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here